[Music]
this is what i did want to ask you uh i
i find that now i i found that you can
either have a tv show or enjoy reading
your at replies on twitter but you can't
have both
people uh that don't even watch the show
love to talk about my fat face and uh
[Music]
and uh how i should kill myself and all
this sort of stuff i understand you have
you have a different approach i'm here
to change your mind really
pete they cannot hurt you
those people cannot hurt you
i i give
you see what you have to you have to get
to a place where
compliments mean as much to you as
insults which is zero okay like i don't
believe a compliment that i get so why
would i give an insult more more credit
you know what i mean that's just i think
that's my problem right there when
someone's like you're sunshine i'm like
you're goddamn right
he gets me yeah he gets me and if
someone's like you suck i'm like ah yeah
they speak to the part of me that thinks
uh you know i'm not so great it's in the
back so what i do is what i do is you
can you can
you can attack them back because you're
a professional comedian you're going to
slay them
you're better at that than they are hey
put a sock in hey
shut your trap i work alone
[Laughter]
[Applause]
but i usually just uh i'll i'll put one
one word in there and then
and then just send it retweet it and
then my followers just pounce on the
person they just pounce on them you
actually source it oh outsource it yeah
exactly someone's like cordray
i take advantage of a mob mentality
right and i get them all riled up you
cut them a little bit and push them in
the shark pool yeah
and then sometimes a day later those
people will be like all right all right
i don't even know who rob cordrey is lay
off
we got to get my father off twitter
we've got to
i like this whole deal by the way are
you okay with it i like i like sitting
like this
i like showcasing our socks
yeah yeah where do you get those um
these socks
yeah what are those hands
i've been sent here to kill your
show uh
[Applause]
you failed you're a delight rob cordrey
everybody
you're great
we're going to be real life friends and
we'll be right back everybody with more
show there's actually more
[Music]